se abre de la fase del mata mata una
eterna aspirante al título se mide
contra un equipo que quiere ser
revelación Países Bajos se mide contra
Estados Unidos lo dijo el seleccionador
neerlandés Luis vangar queremos ser
campeones del mundo estamos a cuatro
partidos de hacerlo con los neerlandeses
que no hay bajas sensibles para este
encuentro cuenta con todos sus efectivos
tienen además a uno de los goleadores
del torneo al delantero del psv kody
capcom que quiero convertirse en el
primer jugador de su país que marca de
manera consecutiva en cuatro partidos en
esta copa mundo además la Orange también
defiende un invicto de 18 partidos con
los norteamericanos la buena noticia
pasa porque Christian pulisic su
delantero y estrella está en condiciones
para este Duelo contra La naranja
mecánica publicista venía con una lesión
en la pelvis y finalmente se estará en
condiciones para este partido un
compañero de publicis Exterminio 10
tiene un sabor distinto tiene un sabor
especial para este encuentro del nació
en los Países Bajos pero juega con
Estados Unidos también hay un especial
para el seleccionador
en este encuentro el seleccionador de
Estados Unidos que cuando fue jugador
disputó seis años en la Liga de Países
Bajos Juan ahora qué podemos esperar del
encuentro entre Argentina y Australia
Cómo llegan los sudamericanos a este
partido
Argentina que llega con la deuda de
demostrar que verdaderamente es una
aspirante al título Se esperan cambios
en el once inicial del director técnico
Lionel escalón y que no ha repetido 11
en esta copa mundo ya para esta ocasión
sabemos por dónde podrían llegar los
cambios El delantero Ángel Di Mariano
hizo parte del último entrenamiento con
la albiceleste tiene una sobrecarga en
el muslo derecho se habla de que en su
lugar podría entrar el papu Gómez o
incluso se especula con que podría tener
sus primeros minutos en este certamen
Ángel Correa con los australianos
comparecieron en rueda de prensa El
seleccionador graham Arnold y el defensa
Harry souther ambos con la misma tónica
nos llaman La Cenicienta Pero podemos
hacerlo dijo concretamente sauther
queremos seguir dando la sorpresa para
esta copa mundo hoy Entonces conoceremos
ya hallados integrantes para los cuartos
de final en Qatar 2022